[Applaudissements]
la scène se passe sur la plage un homme
marche maillot de bain serviette livre à
la main est talent sa serviette
pas très loin d'une personne isolée
derrière lui va nager revient un moment
grave à ses affaires sans varier au
moment de partir de son livre tombe un
billet de 20 euros
cet homme n'est pas un homme exactement
ordinaire stade acteurs et ce site est
une expérience
cette expérience va être refaite 100 x
100 x le même acteur mais s'en faut
évidemment des personnes isolées
différent et on va regarder ce qui se
passe dans tous les cas le biais
ramasser jouera sur produits y est mais
de deux choses l'une
dans cette expérience dans 24 % des cas
le biais est ramassé est rendu à la
personne vous faites le complément il
est discrètement récupérer on refait une
deuxième expérience absolument similaire
à la première
sauf que cette fois ci notre ami acteur
juste avant d'aménager va juste se
retourner vers la personne derrière lui
et lui dire madame ou monsieur pouvez
vous surveiller mes affaires je vous
rappelle les affaires ce une serviette
et un livre je vais nager
il n'attend pas la réponse va nager
revient même chose récupère ses affaires
le biais ton dans ce cas là 70% des
personnes rendent le biais
ce qui fascine dans cette expérience
c'est de voir comment un petit geste
quelques mots ont pu transformer aussi
fortement une relation entre deux
personnes
je m'appelle patrice naudy j'accompagne
des dirigeants depuis plus de 20 ans
j'étais il ya un certain nombre d'années
sur les bancs de cette belle école et
quand je suis sorti de cette école fort
de mes certitudes scientifiques
cartésienne et rationnelle j'étais assez
vite transformé quelques semaines après
transformer parce que je me suis
retrouvé dans une boîte de nuit dont je
distille ya quelques temps ce soir là un
hypnotiseur passé faisait un show alors
pour moi une petite heure c'est juste un
charlatan donc il fait son show à un
moment ils m'ont involontaire givet il
demande pour des la main je tends la
main il m'a un plateau sur la main il
met une boule sur le plateau en métal et
dit maintenant je vais faire chauffer la
baule je vais pas trop voulu en venir
la boule chauffe devient rouge blanche
et autres des flammes sortent de la
boule de plus je me suis dit en fait
c'est pas une teaser c'est un mauvais
magicien pas comme pablo qu'on a vus
avant c'est juste qu'elle tient là une
boule truqués et la boule chauffe
bon ok il n'y a plus qu'à chauffer la
boule un peu plus s'il en effet des
flammes mais de deux mètres de haut
tellement que je sens une chaleur sur
mon visage doit écarter mon visage ce
qui m'a surpris c'est que quand il a
arrêté tout ça il y avait 300 personnes
dans la salle dans la boîte de nuit
je suis le seul à avoir vu des flammes
est alors sorti de la chaleur c'est là
que ce type juste en quelques secondes a
juste pris le contrôle de mon cerveau ça
m'a un peu transformés dans certaines
convictions j'ai toujours eu beaucoup
j'essaie toujours de conviction
scientifique rationnelle mais disons
j'ai élargi un peu mes horizons depuis
ce jour là je me suis interdit intéressé
aux suggestions aux relations humaines
aux émotions
nous vivons dans un monde complexe un
certain ambiguë on l'a vu tout à l'heure
déjà j'ai d'ailleurs une petite remarque
à faire à ce stade où gens qui dans la
salle comme moi ou un petit peu les
cheveux grisonnants il faut qu'on change
de trois trucs pour aller dans ce monde
c'est pas qu'aux jeunes de changer
nous aussi on a certainement notre part
à faire je préfère la parenthèse je
pense qu'il faut changer deux trois
trucs dans ce monde je crois qu'il ya
deux axes clés qui vont nous permettre
le premier parce que je reste cartésien
j'y crois c'est la technologie
je pense qu'il ya plein de solutions
technologiques qui vont pas nous
permettre d'aller vers un avenir
enthousiasmant dans ce monde là alors
que nous savons qu'il ya des scénarios
crédibles qui sont beaucoup moins
enthousiasmant parce que je crois et que
vous avez certainement compris
maintenant c'est que ça suffira pas je
pense que le deuxième axe clé pour être
aller vers un monde enthousiasmant c'est
la confiance
alors la confiance
et qu'est ce que c'est si je vous
demandais à chacun d'entre vous en
trente secondes de me donner votre
définition de la confiance que diriez
vous la définition que je préfère c'est
celle d'un philosophe allemand s'appelle
genre s'y mêlent qu'il a donné cette
magnifique définition aussi simple et
subtil c'est la suspension temporaire du
doute
le monde actuel nous encourage à douter
à douter des autres à douter de l'autre
à douter de soi même la confiance au
contraire de nous encourager à suspendre
se doute que se passe-t-il prenons une
équipe que se passe-t-il dans une équipe
quand la confiance est là tout va plus
vite tu vas pull et parce que
l'information pertinente passes fluide
il ment fluidement les coûts diminuent
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher à beaucoup
de choses on contrôle beaucoup moins la
créativité augmente ça libère la
créativité l'audace se développe
l'engagement augmente c'est beaucoup
plus sympa de travailler dans une équipe
et dans une organisation d'allemand
quand la confiance est là le stress
diminue c'est pas super ça mais pourquoi
on fait pas tous c'est pas très
compliqué vous allez voir mais c'est pas
si facile que ça alors quand j'en arrive
normalement à ce stade là la discussion
avec un dirigeant
ils me disent surtout maintenant ils
sont plus en plus convaincu il dit ouais
c'est super mais en fait j'ai pas le
temps
j'ai pas le temps parce que moi j'ai des
hors jeu assez court terme et tout ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps c'est vraiment
super vraiment j'y crois mais j'ai pas
ça va être trop long à mettre tout ça en
place
elle se trouve c'est hyper intéressant
de se poser la question dont je me suis
posé la question mais combien de temps
faut-il pour bâtir la confiance
alors j'ai commencé par le prendre
problème à l'envers
je me suis dit combien de temps faut-il
pour détruire la confiance si je vous
pose la question pourquoi même temps
pour d'être la confiance ouais j'entends
ce geste là une seconde mais on a à peu
près d'accord
bon vous allez m'aider on lui pose la
question inverse combien de temps
faut-il pour bâtir la confiance c'est
moins clair vos réponses en fait c'est
ma fille qui m'a donné la solution quand
elle avait 18 ans elle m'explique un
jour
voilà ce week-end je pars retrouver des
copains à bordeaux et j'y vais en
voiture avec un inconnu jeudi ma chérie
n'en ai juste pas question est bien
trente secondes plus tard j'ai dit oui
et pourquoi pas ce qu'elle a montré un
site que je ne connaissais pas à
l'époque et qui s'appelle blaquart est
en fait j'ai réalisé qu'elle partait pas
complètement avec un inconnu
elle partait avec jean-paul dans une 308
et surtout jean paul il avait cinq
étoiles sur son profil
et 5 étoiles ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les cinq derniers
voyages qu'il a fait les passagers
étaient dithyrambiques sur jean-paul moi
ça m'a convaincu
mais en fait ça a pris combien de temps
un jean-paul pour voir ses 5 étoiles
s'ils voyagent tous les ans ça lui a
pris cinq ans s'ils voyagent tous les
mois ça lui a pris cinq mois ci voyage
toutes les semaines je vous appelle
calcul la confiance n'est pas une
question dans sa vie est une question de
jalons au cours desquelles vous allez
pouvoir la tester et pour la plupart des
gens c'est entre quatre cinq six mois 5
ça m'a convaincu et c'est intéressant ce
n'est quand même pas beaucoup de gens
qui vont proposer d'accélérer le temps
d'un mois je vous propose une façon
d'accélérer le temps ces dames est
d'accélérer de nullité les jalons c'est
ça qui va permettre d'accélérer
donc en fait c'est pas une question dans
la confiance mais que faut-il alors
parce que question c'est pas tellement
pourquoi c'est vraiment comment comment
on construit la confiance apprenant une
équipe
comment construit la confiance dans une
équipe je crois qu'il ya cinq leviers le
premier j'ai voulu faire tester je vais
vous proposer de sortir vos clés les
clés de chez vous me démontrer mais là
devant vous voilà vous avez encore des
clés normalement à peu près donc j'ai
passé dans les rangs et je vais
emprunter un trousseau pendant les dix
ont une ou deux semaines
je sens une toute petite réticence
normalement si vous êtes en mal de
constituer ou de poser deux questions à
ce stade-là un site choisi comme moi je
veux rentrer chez moi et deux il avait
un gentil sympathique ce garçon mais je
vois pas pourquoi je passerai mes clés
et vous avez raison c'est juste que
quand je dis ça mon intention n'est pas
clair le premier levier de la confiance
s'est clarifié ses intentions te dire
pourquoi on fait ceci et pourquoi on n'a
qu'une seule à l'intention est le
premier levier la confiance
le deuxième si l'intention est caché et
donc vous l'a révélé le deuxième celle
inverse
le deuxième levier sur les comportements
un comportement c'est ce que l'on voit
il ya des comportements qui génère la
confiance
il ya des comportements qui vont contre
et à la détruire on voit les
comportements qui génère la confiance
ils sont pas très compliqué elles sont
pas très compliqué à exprimer dire ce
que l'on fait faire ce que l'on dit
qu'est ce que c'est facile à dire c'est
super puissants c'est simple c'est pas
pour ça que c'est facile dans le monde
actuel de le faire savoir écouter
quelqu'un vraiment en profondeur être
transparent sur ce que l'on fait ah
ouais j'ai une bonne histoire avec un
dirigeant l'année dernière on parle un
peu de ça et bien moi et mon équipe
super transparent j'ai bien je dis par
exemple votre calendrier outlook vous le
partagez avec vos collaborateurs et bien
sûr et je regarde un petit peu en effet
le partage mais certains rendez-vous
sont vraiment partagé et d'autres ses
marques et occuper et quand je dis
d'autres c'est 80 %
là je dis ouais mais c'est pas vraiment
partagé saioni oui mais vous comprenez
moi j'étais en plein de rendez-vous
confidentielles ok on peut les regarder
un parent et un par un on discute de
chacun de ses rendez vous et de
l'intérêt pour lui et pour bâtir la
confiance en équipe qui soit transparent
et un par un ils basculent jusqu'à ce
qu'on arrive mardi suivant mardi suivant
je déjeune avec mon épouse
ça c'est personnel et donc confidentiel
jeudi il ya deux choses l'une soit c'est
interdit mais faut pas le faire monsieur
dirigeants ça c'est pas interdit
qu'est ce que vous avez à crabes d'après
vous ça va faire quoi chez les gens de
savoir où déjeuné avec une personne n'a
le droit de déjeuner plutôt d'avoir un
truc marqué occupés on sait pas trop ce
que vous faites ça va avoir quoi comme
conséquent vous croyez bah ouais bon il
a basculé
là il y eu du mal sur celui-là des
comportements sont clés pour la
confiance
troisième levier la compétence alors là
on peut pas rigoler parce que c'est
quand même clé imagine situation un
petit avion de ligne
un seul pilote à bord l'hôtesse sort du
cockpit en hurlant le pilote vient de
faire un malaise
c'est la panique l'avion commence à
avoir une trajectoire assez douteuse ok
comment savoir panique dans la cabine
êtes assis à votre gauche vous avez
votre meilleur ami vos amis d'enfance
vous le connaissez par coeur ses
intentions sont super clair pour vous il
ya des comportements exemplaires c'est
vraiment quelqu'un vous direz c'est
quelqu'un dont j'ai toute confiance
il ya votre droite vous avez un truc
mais pas sympas depuis le début du
voyage vulgaire grossier qui a une ville
qui vous raconte sa vie depuis le début
du voyage vraiment horrible sauf qu'à
deux minutes il vous a dit que savait
piloter les avions
vous faites confiance à qui dans cette
situation moi je vous encourage
la compétence et clé ça suffit pas les
comportements l'intention mais là confie
de caen ce ça s'acquiert
ici on acquiert de l'incompétence ça se
développe on a peu à prendre toute sa
vie on peut aussi dans une équipe on n'a
pas compétence faire entrer d'autres
personnes mais ne triche pas si la
compétence n'est pas là on n'aura pas
une vraie confiance
quatrième le levier des succès il en
reste un peu paradoxal est en train de
tout depuis tout à l'heure vous
expliquer que pour avoir du succès il
faut développer la confiance et
maintenant je vais vous dire que pour
développer la confiance il faut avoir
des succès mais c'est paradoxal mais ça
peuple comme ça que ça se passe
l'année dernière je travaillais chez edf
je peux citer le nom avec une équipe qui
travaille sur le p r la prochaine
génération de centrales nucléaires dont
parle un peu dans la presse en ce moment
il me dit ce dont on saura le succès de
l'équipe dans 12 ans waouh ça c'est
enthousiasmant les ça va pas le faire
pour la confiance dans l'équipe ça j'ai
la semaine prochaine vous faites quoi
la semaine prochaine semaine banal oui
mais on va regarder un peu plus moi je
vous dis vous pouvez avoir vous pouvez
décider d'avoir un succès la semaine
prochaine
c'est quoi un succès c'est quelque chose
que l'on souhaite avoir notre on n'est
pas certain de la mois et la semaine
suivante il devait présenter un rapport
à son patron t'es pas sûr d'avoir le
budget pour ça il pense qu'elle est 30%
de chances d'avoir un budget il devait
recruter 4 a été patient cette personne
de lier viennent peut-être que il avait
50 % de chances que ça personnes
viennent mais je lui dis si vous faites
troy cate actions comme ça fait un peu
des stades quoi la semaine prochaine
vous allez en avoir un succès donc juste
définissez mais c'est même plus que
définissez décidé d'aller à succès la
semaine prochaine et roulera parce que
le succès et les succès vont générer la
confiance 5e levier peut-être le plus
surprenant la vulnérabilité
alors on s'attendre on parle de
confiance de confiance dans une équipe
de confiance en soi a du charisme
il faut être sûr de soi il faut qu'on va
ne faut pas montrer 12 faiblesse et bien
moi je vous propose la verse et il n'y a
pas longtemps un directeur du marketing
m'a fait cet extraordinaire cadeau de
montrer ça en live
il présentait au board la défense d'un
projet deux semaines après son équipe
avait bossé depuis six mois sur le
projet son équipe avait super bien bossé
et lui dit on n'est pas prêt enfin je
suis pas prêt enfin je le sens pas on a
tous les éléments et je pas pourquoi je
me sens pas je suis en train de paniquer
je me sens pas du tout près ça va pas le
faire du tout il devait rejoindre son
équipe pour finaliser cette présentation
et avant de rentrer une des banques
faut quand même que j'assure jeu prend
une grande respiration je vais quand
même leur dire que tout va bien qu'on va
y arriver même si au fond de moi même je
crois pas du tout il rentre il commence
un peu comme ça et un moment il s'arrête
et je sens prend une grande respiration
beaucoup de recul et le redis je suis en
train de vous raconter des bobards
c'est super bien bossé mais moi je suis
en train de paniquer j'y crois pas à ce
projet
je crois que je me plantais grand
silence dans la salle
et là une petite stagiaire qui était là
depuis deux mois qu'ils vous voyait
encore les vlaming dit monsieur est ce
qu'on peut vous aider
c'est un moment magique pour lui pour
l'équipe car ce moment aurait pu être un
moment de panique
c'est un moment de féerie dans cette
équipe dans la semaine qui a suivi et il
est allé
les cinq leviers de la confiance dans
une équipe l'intention les comportements
la vulnérabilité des succès la
compétence le monde dans lequel nous
sommes nous encourage à douter tout
doute et des autres doté du système tout
et la société doute elle nous mêmes
osons suspendre ce doute aux autres la
confiance merci
[Applaudissements]